(mouse clicking)
(computer beeping)
(bright piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained,
long the master of fire,
tools and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly, we hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
(soft piano music)
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here,
an exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
(bright music)
(imaginative music)
- I will, I'll show the work that we do,
and in a way, is quite similar
to the Kennis brothers,
we try to reconstruct
parts of the Neanderthal,
but instead of body parts,
what we try to do is to
reconstruct their minds.
And one day, I imagine
that would be possible,
and I don't have a
brother to challenge me,
keep it going, but I have a whole team,
and these whole team
help me to achieve that,
and that's what I'm gonna
share with you guys.
Shall we start with the idea that perhaps
we should study human imaginations
by comparing to other humans, perhaps,
humans that have a different
kind of imagination,
either worse or better, just different.
And we thought about the Neanderthals,
and part of the reason
is because we know more
about the Neanderthals than
the other extinct hominins,
and we also share our world
with them for a long time.
And becomes clear, and I think you guys
all learned about that,
that during the time period
that the Neanderthals, they stay on earth,
I mean, they developed these stones tools
and definitely make it
better, but technology
didn't go as far as that, and in contrast,
we modern humans, in a
very short period of time,
we could create not only stone tools,
but a whole set of new technology, art,
and sophisticated ways to
communicate to each other,
which points out that perhaps our brains
are somehow different from them.
So, how do we study the Neanderthals,
and how we can start
tracking these questions?
So we have bones, we have endocast,
if we can predict how their brains
would have a different shape or volume.
We have DNA, we can extract DNA from bones
of Neanderthals, and we have impressions,
and someone might call that art,
others might not think that this is art,
but they definitely left
some impressions for us
to try to understand.
So from the endocast, this
is the work from the group
from Leipzig, in Germany,
they have confirmed
that their brains, at
least in terms of volume,
is not so different than us.
They actually have a
little bit larger brain
compared to what we have, but, I mean,
the endocast doesn't offer too much
in terms of how that
brain actually functioned.
So, and Svante Paabo, also from Leipzig
is a pioneer on isolating the DNA
from the Neanderthals and sequence them
so we can actually compare
the Neanderthal genome
to the modern humans, so this is all nice,
but actually, how do we
understand the Neanderthal brain
or the Neanderthal mind in a dish?
So I come from the stem cell background,
and in stem cells, we
have something called
brain organoid, also called a mini-brain
because we can recreate those
using human pluripotent stem cells,
and they don't look like that,
(audience laughs)
they are actually a simplify,
miniaturized version
of the human brain, and we have a recipe
that we develop in the lab
that is quite good to make
a functional mini-brains
or brain organoids, and it always starts
from single cells, these
are single to embryonic
stem cells or pluripotent stem cells
that we can reprogram from people.
It can do it from my cells,
from your cells as well.
So from these single cells, we grow them
in different media,
changing the grow factors,
specific grow factors at different stages
and see what we can mature them
in these networks, we just form and become
more and more sophisticated.
Another thing is that, I mean,
they can grow up to a half centimeter
and we can keep them
alive for up to two years.
So these are quite robust protocols,
because not only you create a single one,
but you can create
thousands of brain organoids
in this same batch, so that allows you
to do some experiments with them.
And if you cut one of those spheres,
what you can see is that they maintain
or they mimic some of the
embryonic brain structures
in humans by having a ventricular zone
in the center that sends
out, that migrate out
and form what we call the cortical plate.
As these organoids age,
these cortical layers
will become more and more well defined.
So this is a snapshot
of all the cell types
that we have if we just
age these brain organoids
for about four month, we
have mostly glutamatergic,
these are excitatory
neurons, and you start
to see two populations in there,
so these would be upper
and lower cortical layers,
but we also have
inhibitory neurons as well.
A small population of GABAergic neurons.
There are presenter cells
that continue to produce,
and at that stage we start
to see some glial cells
or astrocyte, these are the cell types
that helps on the formation
of these complex networks
that we gonna, I'm gonna show you
how they behave later on.
So this is all good, but I can,
I need live cells to recreate
those brain organoids
in a dish, and the problem
is there is no live cells
from the Neanderthals, so
that poses a big problem.
How can we recreate the Neanderthal mind
if we don't have the
raw material for that?
So we turned to genetics,
since we have their genome,
one thing that is possible to do
is to compare the genome
of the Neanderthals
to modern humans, and we
have thousands of them,
and ask, what are the differences
between those genomes?
What is specific to modern humans
that were positive selected
in us, compared to them?
So, if we look across all the genes,
we end up with about 200 genes,
and this is, many people have been mining
these dataset, and these are the genes
that are different between
modern humans and Neanderthals.
And instead of looking
for all these genes,
we decided to narrow done this list
to three genes, because we had asked
what are the ones that
are highly expressed
during early stages of neural development
and what are the ones that we know
that if they are mutated in modern humans
will lead to a neurological disorder?
And these are the three genes,
these two here are synaptic genes,
they will help how the
synaptic or the connections
between neurons are formed, and that one
is a very interesting one,
because it starts very early
and it's a master regulator of all,
of several down string genes,
it's a splicing regulator,
a splicing protein.
So the way we do that
is using genome editing,
and we use CRISPRs where we can go back
to one of our modern human cell lines
and we can change or swap
the genetic information
from the modern humans
to the Neanderthals.
So we Neanderthalize the cell lines,
targeting those specific genes,
and at the end of the
day, we have Neanderthal
brain organoids or Neanderthoids,
how we call them, and we can compare.
So, I mean, we done
that, we recreate that,
and I will show you
some of the differences
that we observe by comparing
them with the modern humans.
So the first big difference is
at the gene expression level.
What are the genes that
are up or down regulated
compared to us, and we
have a couple of them.
The interesting part is
that they are all connected
to brain development, and
several pathways that leads
to brain formation, now I'll
point to some of them here.
This is just a list of interesting genes
that we are trying to
understand, there are genes
such as nesting, which
is a progenitor cell,
early stages of neuro brain formations.
There are genes such
as TPR1, this is a gene
that has been implicated
in autism, for example,
and they are down
regulated in Neanderthals.
And there are genes like
OTX, that when up regulated
might prone you to have
seizures or epilepsy.
So this all happens with
down genetic modification,
I mean, it's just by
changing those early genes
that you affect downstream
genetic signature
that might lead to problems
such as autism or epilepsy.
So, I told you about one of the genes
that are actually a master regulator
and controls how gene expression
or splicing is regulated,
and this is a gene called
NOVA1, and this is a reconstruction
of the protein attached to the RNA
in exactly that the base pair from the DNA
that changes, altered that conformation
and as a consequence the RNA splicing
would be affected as well,
and we are looking into these
altered splicing factors,
and we realize that
there's a lot of information in there.
Some genes like HOMER1, this
is another synaptic gene,
have different isoforms between humans
and Neanderthals during development.
All the genes, and these
are actual target of NOVA1,
they, such as GNAS or BiN1, so these are
genes involving the epigenetic
regulation, for example.
They create a new
isoform that only present
in Neanderthals, modern
humans lost that isoform
from that specific protein,
so these are quite interesting
observations at the gene expression level.
What happens to these brain organoids
if they have that?
So, the morphology is quite interesting.
They start quite similar,
but as they progress in time,
you can tell that the
morphology changes a lot.
So, while the modern
humans brain organoids
become sphere, increasing size,
and start to mature, the
Neanderthal brain organoids
have these kind of popcorn shape,
and, well, you can measure
the diameter of them,
I mean, how they grow,
and already we can see
that the Neanderthal
organoids probably have
some kind of cell death,
or some problems to develop
compared to modern humans.
Also, the size of the sphere is different,
but also, I mean, the way those spheres
are shaped, which might point it out
to some differences, as I said,
in cell death or apoptosis,
but also in migration,
the way the cells migrate.
So just by looking at these pictures,
we can tell that there
is migration defects
and there is a way to test that,
you can plate some of these cells
and let them migrate by themselves,
and what we observe is
that the Neanderthal cells,
they have a defect in migration,
they migrate is slower,
but they go farther
than human cells, so it's,
even a small migration
might affect your entire brain's
trajectory during development.
So if you look at the neurons,
I mean, we also see
differences in specific subtype
of populations from
the cortex, this is one
of the cortical layers,
and we observe that SATB2,
it's a neuron that participates
on intra-cortical communication,
as well as intra
communications between layers.
It is dramatically reduced
in Neanderthal cell lines
compared to controls.
So, everything is all about morphology
and how the cells behave, or
the shape of these organoids.
What about the function?
Can we actually measure
how the communication
or the network is being affected?
So to do that we use a tool that is called
a multi electrode array,
where we plate these brain organoids
into multi electrode, in
the bottom of those dishes,
and we can record, we gain an activity map
as well as a raster plot
in every trace here,
it's when a neuron spikes, and if you have
several spikes at the same
time, we call that a burst,
and when bursts spikes
in the same channel,
we call a synchrony event.
And since we can keep them alive,
we can see that they
evolve, and we did that.
And when we start, we actually
didn't have what to compare,
so I'm showing you here,
just some of the work
that we did in 2D, this is without
the two dimension restructure,
and most of the data,
it is below five hertz,
so this is just a average
measure of the brain activity,
so what is the ideal, what is our goal?
So, a mouse brain is about 18 hertz,
and a monkey brain is about 20 hertz.
So other people have also
created different protocols
for brain organoids, and
although they can also keep them
alive for a long period of time,
they were not able to see
an increase in activity,
suggesting that there is some
problems with maturation.
But we are glad that the protocol we have,
we were able, not only to keep them alive,
but to reach a level of activity
that's much higher than was ever
recorded before in vitro,
so if you have that much
level of activity in
synaptogenesis going on,
it means that you can
record something else,
and this is what we call brain
oscillations or brain waves,
the activity that can actually
measure through the skulls
using electro encephalogram or EEG.
So, we can actually
measure those EEG waves
from these brain organoids,
and we can compare
them to pre-term babies, so we created
these machine learning
algorithm and we trained that
in an unsupervised way, by exposing them
to different EEGs from preterm babies,
and asking the machine to tell the age
of the person, so once
the machine has done that,
we feed them with our
brain organoid's EEG,
and we ask, what are the
predicted age of the organoids?
So, this is how the machine will do,
in a perfect condition in the red trace,
the data is actually on
the black trace as well,
where you can see that we
have a very good prediction
to above 25 weeks, and the reason why
the machine is not good to predict
below that, is because
we simply don't have
any data from human
pre-term babies below that.
The babies will die,
and we don't have a way
to record in uterus that is not invasive,
so that's why we don't
have a good prediction.
But what is the prediction
that we can have,
and I will show you just one example
of one of the parameters from the EEG,
which is the space between the interval
of activities, so if you
just look an adult EEG here,
so it's quite complex.
This is a pre-term baby,
you see these spontaneous
activity transient followed
by quiescent period,
where the brain's just silent,
when you're super young, and
here is in our brain organoid.
So the brain organoid's much
similar to a pre-term baby
than to adult brain, so
that's what we are modeling.
We are modeling early
stages of neuro development,
so as we grow older, the interval
between those activity
becomes shorter and shorter,
that's why we have this
complex EEG in adult.
So the organoid, as we age the organoid,
the interval also reduces, and reduces
to a level that gets close to that red bar
about 40 weeks, or nine month,
that's equivalent to a
newborn healthy human baby.
So that's what we can get
with these human organoids.
So now that we have lots
of activity to compare,
I mean, how does the
Neanderthal brain organoids
compare to modern humans?
So we have been studying
that from different angles,
and I'll first start by showing
what is the level of synaptogenesis,
how many brain cell connections
the Neanderthals can make
compared to modern humans.
And we see that there
is almost 50% reduction,
which is similar to someone
with autism, for example.
So, definitely a lower level
of synapsis compared to controls.
We also measured them on
the multi electrode arrays,
and what we have here in these parts
is just the raster plot, the activity map,
and then, some of the
quantifications that we have.
The number of spikes,
the level of activity
per neuron per minute is way reduced
to what we would expect
for an isogenic control.
The same is true for the firing rate,
for these neurons is also reduced
compared to isogenic controls,
which, again, points to the fact
that these networks are
just not good enough
or not mature enough, to the level
that we would expect from modern humans.
So, I hope I could tell
you that by recreating
these Neanderthal brain in a dish
we could say that they have differences
in morphology, in synaptogenesis,
even at the network
level, but the question is
are those differences better or worse
than the modern humans?
And I made some analogies with autism
and other neurological disorders,
but the truth is that we don't know.
So we have been looking
that, using different
experimental models and I'll just show you
one thing that we are excited about,
and this came from this
idea that if you have
brain oscillations from
people working together,
they might actually synchronize,
or they are more prone to work
if your friend is with
you than a stranger,
which suggests that, to achieve something,
to achieve a specific
goal, it's better to work
with someone that you like.
So we have been tagging
these human brain organoids
into robots, so that's a way for the robot
to experiment the world,
and we are doing that
in two ways, the first step
is just teaching the organoid
how to move a robot, and that's what
you're gonna be seeing this video.
So this is a robot that has been moving
all the legs just by the frequency
of oscillations coming from
the human brain organoid.
So the idea is now, to do the second step,
which is to create the feedback loop,
so the organoid can
actually learn something
and the robot can tell by
experiencing the world.
So soon, we gonna be
doing the same experiments
using Neanderthal brain organoids,
we can see if the robot can
actually learn something
better or not than humans.
So, I'll finish here by summarizing
that we have a model,
a brain organoid model
coming from stem cells
that can recapitulate
human development, we can
reconstruct evolutionary steps
that recapitulate key
features of the Neanderthal
development, we think
so, and these might be
a paradigm for learning, if you put them
back to a robot or something.
So these are Cleber and Priscilla,
these are the brain masters in the lab,
they are the ones who
develop these nice protocol
that everybody's excited about,
and these are my collaborators
for this project,
both Katerina Semendeferi, Yeo Lab,
the Voytek Lab, and Eric Green,
who help us on the genomic
analysis of Neanderthals.
And these are my funding agencies,
and I will stop here, thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
(bright music)